last week i was busy writing the script
for my origami king review when i
suddenly had
an eye-opening revelation i suck at
writing game reviews
i was a few pages in and started proof
reading the first few paragraphs and i
thought to myself
oh this is so boring sometimes you
stumble upon things that just
aren't you if you know what i mean and
writing a structured review based on a
checklist or blueprint you know
gameplay story replayability all that
jazz it just doesn't work for me i don't
aspire to be a gaming journalist or a
nintendo news reporter
not only are you competing with teams of
people who have the speed time manpower
not to mention the experience to hammer
out well constructed reviews but i like
to think of my videos as little passion
projects with my own twist to it so i
thought to myself
screw it i threw my original script out
the window and decided to do this
my way and just talk about my experience
and opinions
and after i'm done saying what i want to
say you can decide for yourself whether
or not you think this game is worth your
time and money
or maybe you already played it yourself
and just like to hear my opinion about
it that's cool too
that being said in order to truly
express my feelings about this game i
will have to go into milk spoiler
territory
i will try my best to show things with
as little context as possible so the
story stays
somewhat unspoiled but at some point in
the video i will talk about and show
locations and events that play out later
in the game
and of course i will give a proper
spoiler warning when the time comes
so without further ado let's unfold
this little adventure
alright let's get this out of the way
first i want to briefly touch upon the
divisiveness and negativity this game
received upon release
and even before it saw the light of day
now look i love the older games
the thousand year door is one of my
favorite games of all time
i am one of those fanboys to give a
quick rundown of my experience with the
series paper mario 64 which i played
first was
amazing the thousand year door was
amazing er
super paper mario i greatly enjoyed
however due to the game being so
radically different gameplay wise i
always treated it more as
sort of a spin-off game a mix between
super mario
and paper mario sticker star can go
for itself and color splash i never
played
this was a conscious decision by me at
the time because frankly the game just
gave me too much sticker star ptsd
you ain't fooling me nintendo calling
them cards is not gonna magically make
me forget that the cards are the same
thing
as stickers simply put everything this
game presented to me at the time just
didn't spark my interest
so i can totally sympathize with those
of you who are still on the fence about
giving origami king a try
60 bucks is a lot of money and if you're
a cheap bastard like me
you might want to save those benjamin
franklin's or in my case
roman architecture for something you
know you're going to enjoy and support
and to those people i say all the power
to you
however there is a special breed of
gamers out there
these rare specimens have made it their
mission not to just voice their distaste
of a game but to make sure that the
whole world knows it and seem to find
great enjoyment in making sure the game
fails on every conceivable level because
it isn't what they want it to be
even if you genuinely feel the game
isn't good the game is not worth a zero
guys
just the fact that the game boots up and
runs well is already worth a point
you know what i did when color splash
came out nothing
i just said nope not for me and i picked
up some games i
actually liked playing what a novel
concept right now i get that for some
people the new direction of the series
is disappointing
i do i too would have loved to see
another thousand year door type of game
but
continuously crying over spilled milk
and fighting tooth and nail to get your
points across
isn't doing anyone any favors there are
three
amazing games out there that are right
up your alley you can always go back to
and play again paper mario is just one
of many
many franchises out there and the world
is not going to end because
one series is no longer going in the
direction you want it to
in other news the world is going to end
throughout the course of my playthrough
of the game my reaction slowly evolved
from
all right to all right too
this game freaking rules you can have
rave parties involving trees
vandalize walls race around in a piece
of footwear
throw confetti around like a stage
magician play the wind waker
and of course take your aggression out
on helpless toads
while i didn't play color splash i do
think that the game looked amazing and i
don't think the graphics were ever the
issue for most people
sticker star started this whole paper
and cardboard aesthetic but whereas that
game looks bland and empty
origami king is just bursting with life
and color one single screen just
bombards you with all kinds of little
details
some might prefer the mix between the 2d
characters in the 3d environment seen in
the first two games but for me
this paper crafted world just works very
well and it's not like everything is too
abstract either
houses still look like houses furniture
like furniture and zonai dungeon statues
like zonai dungeon statues
and it's actually interesting to see how
these objects are constructed using
these materials
i don't think the environments in
thousand year door were bad by any means
but this world presented in origami king
just
makes sense to me and complements the
paper inhabitants
story-wise the game is definitely more
simplistic and this is one of the few
things i do think the older games just
flat out did better
pun intended thousand year door didn't
necessarily have the most complex story
but it's the amazing substories in each
chapter that made it so great from a
mystery on a train to a fighting ring in
which fighters have been disappearing
under suspicious circumstances to a town
of shadow people who are one by one
turning into pigs with each chime of a
mysterious bell
you name it what i do like about origami
king though is the fact that they did
away with the whole
collect the seven thingamajigs to win
game that stuff was getting old anyway
origami king is more of a point a to b
type of adventure you
are constantly following the various
streamers which have mummified peach's
castle
and while you could consider toad town
to be the central hub of the game
it doesn't necessarily feel like it
aside from buying stuff and collecting
extras you only really need to come back
here i think
two times if you're only sticking to the
main storyline whereas in thousand year
door you always went back to rogueport
in between chapters and figure out where
to go next from there which was fine but
origami king's approach isn't
necessarily worse just
different and it definitely beats the
hell out of the level select system from
color splash and sticker star
i will talk a little bit more about the
story in a later point of the video but
first i want to get the battle system
out of the way
this is by far the most controversial
part of the game and the only thing i'm
really conflicted about
on the one hand i kinda like it and i
commend nintendo for trying something
new
i'm not going to go in depth and explain
all the little intricacies about the
battle system there's plenty of videos
out there who will gladly lay it out for
you but the main gist of it is you spin
the arena to line up enemies in either
squares or lines
lines are for jumping squares for
hammering a good lineup results in your
attacks dealing 1.5 times the damage
there's weapons you can equip items you
can use and surprisingly enough
the game does have sort of a badge
system to increase your damage defense
or get some extra time to figure out the
proper lineup during each turn
it's not nearly as expensive as the
badges in a thousand year door but
hey it's there and then there's the boss
battles which last considerably longer
and all have their own way of
approaching the fight
some mess with the arena some have
devastating attacks which need to be
avoided or can only be defeated using
specific attacks or special moves
i never found the battles to be boring
or tedious to the point that it ruined
the game for me
and this is coming from someone who
absolutely sucks at this stuff
there have been more than enough moments
where i just couldn't figure out the
proper lineup and had to either spend a
lot of money to literally buy myself
more time or just settle with weaker
attacks than i care to admit
there is however one glaring issue and
one which i definitely side with the
critics on
the battles are not rewarding enough
there are for instance no experience
points
nintendo's stubbornness to not include
more incentive to willingly take part in
these fights
is one that will forever be one of
life's greatest mysteries
it really isn't rocket science here guys
if you're gonna have a turn-based battle
system you gotta reward
the player all you get is coins and
coins are not exactly hard to come by
even while avoiding most battles i still
managed to bill gates my way through
this game
i never even came close to running out
and i think nintendo was fully aware of
this problem
and it almost seems like they purposely
worked around it not by having a level
system or at the very least have enemies
drop good weapons or helpful items but
by making certain enemies
unavoidable this doesn't happen too
often so again it's not like you're
going to be forced into a battle every
few minutes
but it is kind of hilarious that this is
their solution to the problem
most of the regular overworld enemies
are painfully easy to avoid which
like i said seems like it was almost
done on purpose remember how in thousand
year door
you had enemies that just came flying at
you at mach 5 from off-screen and you're
like oh
[ __ ] are these piranha plants who spring
up all over the place
yeah compare that to origami king's
enemies
oh wait wait wait a second wait bro
go away although the game does lose a
few points on this i stand by the fact
that this is by no means game breaking
i never really played paper mario games
for the combat system
as someone who's played his fair share
of rpgs as far as rpgs go even thousand
year door had the most bare bones
stripped down iteration of a turn-based
battle system
and this was done on purpose the games
were always meant to be accessible for
everyone
as opposed to more complex rpgs with hit
points ranging into the thousands
party management jobs skill trees and
tons of gear with various status effects
paper mario has always kept it simple
and i don't remember
ever having to grind to be able to beat
it for me the biggest reason for picking
up a paper mario game has always been
the story the characters and the humor
which
origami king has in spades speaking of
story
uh-oh comedically large spoiler alert
from this point on i will be showing
quite some stuff about the mid to late
game so if you're still planning on
picking it up pause the video
play the game and i will see you again
in about 15 to 20 hours
first off the characters the characters
in this game
rock olivia alone is probably one of the
best companion characters in the series
including thousand year door
she's like that optimistic friend you
always want to bring with you on a night
out because you know you're gonna have a
good time
she's witty she's charming and managed
to get more than enough chuckles out of
me
but she's not there for just comedic
relief either as even she has her
moments in the story where she struggles
with something or is sad and depressed
and you are tasked with
cheering her up which i was more than
happy to do her dialogue is great and by
the end of the adventure you really feel
like you have bonded with her
aside from olivia there is a plethora of
characters which tag along with you for
a while
characters like bobby who has a great
character arc and kamek who is really
funny
especially when interacting with
characters like olivia and bowser jr
they aren't always the most helpful in
combat as you have no control over their
actions but they do
attack enemies when they feel like it
sure it might not be on the level of the
first two games where you can use their
special abilities and control them in
combat their biggest contribution is
complementing the narrative and just
like with olivia there's some hilarious
and even
touching moments to be had with them
seeing all these characters interact
with each other even in real time while
you explore the overworld
really adds to the charm of the game the
main antagonist king ali who is olivia's
brother
isn't necessarily the most memorable
mario villain ever
but it's still a big step up from color
splash which went back to bowser being
the main bad guy
and in origami king you actually have
that classic team up with bowser later
in the game and
he is funny as he's ever been some have
criticized ali's motivations for doing
what he does but
come on it's a mario villain not a metal
gear solid antagonist
it's not like there's a high standard
here he's just a very emo guy who wants
to take over the world
each chapter in the game sees you
visiting many different locations all
with their own look and feel and little
substory to go with it
not only that but origami king is a game
that just keeps on giving i was
pleasantly surprised just how many
different things this game makes you do
one moment you're racing around the
desert in a shoe next you're suddenly in
a quiz show
exploring an ocean and fishing for
treasures or you're in a first person
aerial battle shooting
bombs at incoming paper planes just look
at these little guys go
this is what they live for blowing
themselves up for the greater good you
gotta respect it
this game is like a party that just
keeps on going
speaking of parties confetti when i
first saw the trailers and gameplay
demonstrations i thought this confetti
mechanic was going to play a much bigger
role in the game but unlike color splash
and its paint mechanic the confetti
isn't used in combat
at all the only function it serves is to
cross specific gaps or get
coins and if you're ocd like me you're
gonna want to fill every hole in the
wood no
no no i shouldn't phrase it like that
repair every gap in the fabric of
reality just because it feels good to do
and you get coins for it in return which
is nice
other than that the confetti is just
there i think there's only
two instances where the game
artificially drains your confetti to a
point where you have to search around
for more in order to progress
aside from that it can literally be
found everywhere by bashing every tree
plant or flower which is funny because
at the end of each chapter the game
makes this whole big triumphant deal out
of the fact that your confetti bag has
now expanded
oh okay cool
thanks the same thing goes for the
thousand-fold arms which
outside of battles isn't even used that
much other than little interactions with
the world here and there
but in terms of battles i gotta say it
does feel good bashing away at an enemy
using the motion controls
yeah look at this this is brutal oh damn
the bosses as characters were definitely
not on par with the older games
but as i stated before the battles
themselves were entertaining for me
and somehow i find it kind of hilarious
that they are simply office supplies
each one does have its own personality
believe it or not colored pencils is a
snobby artist rubber band is a
flamboyant lover of theater and drama
and hole punch is a passionate disco
queen just to name a few
again they are no hooktail or grubba but
at the same time
they are nowhere near as bad and
uninspired as some people made them out
to be
and the way they all have their own
unique traits when it comes to boss
battles like taping the rings together
so you are limited in the way you spin
the arena or how hoe punch takes away
parts of mario's body and decreases his
total hp
makes each one a joy to fight in how
many games are you trying to get your
face back
and i don't mean metaphorically i mean
literally your face is gone
there it is now you have to go get it
back exactly
each battle feels like a puzzle you need
to solve and i
happen to like puzzles even though i'm
bad at them lastly and i think this goes
without saying the music is great as
always
there's so many different tracks in
different styles you can really tell
that the composers had a lot of fun with
this one
all in all i think the game is just a
great little adventure with a lot of
enjoyable moments
the series might not be what it used to
be but that doesn't take away from the
fact that it's obvious that a lot of
love was poured into this game
in fact i think the best way to approach
this game is to just forget that the
thousand year door exists
just take that game set it aside for a
while
and just try to enjoy what is here it's
not a bad game
on the contrary it's a not bad game aka
good
not every game has to be that big
blockbuster or lightning in a bottle
type of game
and just the sheer existence of the
thousand year door is not a valid
argument to hate on origami king it's
meant to be experienced as a standalone
fun little adventure
since this isn't a real review i'm not
gonna rate the game but i would put it
in the same category as luigi's mansion
three
just fun little experiences with some
clever puzzles
simple yet effective stories and some
genuinely funny moments
now if you'll excuse me i have some
whacking to do
[Music]
you